Hello everyone, I'm Sushil Bharati from Nepal.
Hello my name is Chris Marchand.
My name is Srinivasan, I'm from Bangalore, India.
My name is Abbas Jaffary, I'm an adjunct mathematics
instructor at Morraine Valley Community College.
I first learned about OCW when I was in high
school. And I remembered looking at it and
just thinking about how great all of MIT's
classes seemed.
I have seen news about OpenCourseWare in the
internet. Then I fell in love with it.
My first reaction when I read about OCW was...wow
it can't be true. It's too good to be true
as a matter of fact.
The resources online, you'd be amazed at what
kids would be interested in learning if you
just show them a little bit about prime numbers
or areas or tangent lines.
When I first realized that the MIT course
content was free for students i was like...wow
this is amazing.
You can't put a value on the lectures, because
it's just absolutely invaluable.
And it was something that really just made me want
to go to MIT.
I've always admired MIT as an institution
and I said okay this is what the kids over
there are doing, this is what instructors
are doing. We can all do this, just pay attention,
look at what's going on.
Thank you MIT.
For opening your books.
For opening your doors.
For opening your hearts.
I am course 6.867 Machine Learning.
I am course 1801.
I am 18.06 Linear Algebra.
You may not know me.
I know you may not know me.
But I am your student.
And you are my professor.
So thank you.
Thank you.